hello everyone
thanks for coming I'm Stefan I'm a
software engineer at Google will work on
compilers and runtime systems and most
recently I've been working on our age
which is Google's new shrinker for
Android applications now if you attended
yesterday's session on new compilers in
Android studio you already heard a fair
bit about whatever it is and how you can
use it and today I don't want to talk
too much actually what our rate is I
want to focus more on keep rules so what
are keep rules keep rules is the
configuration language that ProGuard
uses to specify the things you need to
keep in your application while shrinking
and when we build our rate we decided we
wanted to use the same language because
we wanted to be a drop-in replacement
for ProGuard the idea being that he
could just reuse your existing rules and
try our aid really easily nice you might
imagine building something that is
compatible to that degree required us to
quite deeply understand what program
rules actually mean and today I want to
use this opportunity to share some of
that knowledge with you and I also want
to take on a little journey to
understand what it really takes given an
application to come up with effective
keep rules to shrink it to its minimum
but before we go there let me ask you
all the questions so who of you has used
ProGuard before in some way or shape wow
that's a lot of people so who of you is
using ProGuard today in a released
production app on the Play Store that's
really little less but you're a great
crowd thank you for doing that because
our estimates show that only about a
quarter of applications on the Play
Store actually use keep rules so there's
a big room for improvement and I want to
talk a little bit about why it actually
matters to shrink application size so of
course for me it matters because I
helped build the shrinker right I'm
interested that somebody uses it but it
should also matter for you there has
been a lot of talk about next billion
users entry level Android devices and
how we can make their user experience
better and what makes an entry level
user Android device so one thing is
it's really resource-limited so if you
think of these devices they typically
have as less as 512 megabytes of RAM or
they might only have like 4 gigabytes of
storage and quite often people that use
these devices on areas where they have
very limited connectivity so for these
users size actually makes a daily
difference right when they decide of all
the apps they actually want to use which
once they can afford to install there
might be a small subset and that's bad
for them because it's a bad user
experience but it's also really bad for
you as application developers because it
might be your app that doesn't make the
cuts it might be your app that they
actually want to use but they can't use
because they don't have the space now
you might say ok that's not really my
audience next billion users entry level
that's not where I'd see my application
but even if your target really high end
devices the fundamental truth is that
smaller is always faster and that's
quite obvious because a they download
faster because they're smaller there's
less to transfer they also install a lot
faster because there's less code to
compile and that what takes the time at
installing and lastly and that's what
users see every day they also start up
much faster because there's less code to
load so whenever I talk to people about
this and say ok you have to care you
have to make them smaller an answer I
get really really often is yeah but you
know hardware will fix this right
devices are becoming faster there's more
storage connectivity is better that
might be true but it's not a solution I
have a graph for you so this shows the
average size of installed apps on
people's devices and as you can see this
has been growing steadily so in the
early days of Android we started at
about a megabyte per apk and by now we
are they're whopping 32 megabytes on
average for installed applications so
clearly hardware is not gonna fix this
we have to do something about it we have
to make ab smaller so let's look at this
where does this gross come from why are
absol big and to get an idea I thought
I'd bring you a little example AB so I
built this app which
simple weather and the stress really is
on simple because all this F does it
takes some statically predefined weather
data and then renders it as a dynamic
graph dynamic graph means if you turn
the app it will render in a different
size of you install it on a different
device it will adapt a resolution so the
graph is truly dynamic the data isn't
and this is a really really simple app
there's two things that I found
surprising when I built this app the
positive thing was it took me over 30
minutes I just went on the internet I
look for a graph library I typed in
about a hundred lines of code and there
was my little simple weather app but it
was also a negative surprise and that
was the sighs I thought I built
something simple and small because that
makes it small but that's not sure this
app was 2 megabytes of an apk 2
megabytes just for rendering a graph and
even worse when I install this it turns
into a for megabyte blob of code because
it was uncompressed and again you might
say ok 4 megabytes that's not really
much right the advice is lots of space
lets me put that a little perspective
for you if you look back into the 60s we
flew to the moon with 60 K of code why
that's the 60th of the application size
I had for my simple weather here and no
matter how you turn this it's tricked me
more complicated to fly to the moon than
rendering a graph so what has happened
here why did we go from 60 K flying to
the moon to 4 megabytes rendering a
graph and I think the reason is that we
fundamentally changed how we do software
so back then when they did the software
for Apollo there was a dedicated team
that brought this code line by line
everything was on purpose
everything was handcrafted so what's
really meticulously crafted to fit into
this 60 K and 2 exactly one thing fly to
the moon fast forward to today how
Bhilai my app I use components I just
went to the web downloaded some
components ditched it altogether
tada I had my app there's a great
advantage of this right it took me only
30 minutes it was really easy I was
super productive but there's also a big
big drawback
my application was really big so let's
look into the details which components
did I actually use for that I brought
you my built a Gradle file and this is
essentially the default file that
Android studio will generate for you and
all I've done I've added two components
I've highlighted them here so that it's
easier for you to see the first one is
guava now guava
that's Google's common components for
software engineering Java and they add a
lot of convenient classes and the thing
I wanted was immutable collections
because I thought my static weather data
its static so it should be an immutable
collection right that's good software
engineering practice the other thing I
use is Android plot and that's just a
library I found on the internet there's
probably lots more of plotting libraries
but I'd spotted this one the first an
Android plot is really great it has lots
of support for bar graphs and all kinds
of charts but I will really need it a
line graph that's all I cared about
so let's look what this means for size
how did these components impact the size
of my application and to get an idea I
went to the apk analyzer now if you
haven't seen this tool before it's
regrade it's part of android studio you
will find documentation on developers
Android comm but what this does is it
gives you a deep insight into what
contributes to the size of your apk I
can't do resources on all kinds of
things but I'm only interested here in
the actual code so I've highlighted that
at the bottom there for you there's this
conch Google package which contributes
1.4 megabytes
well that's guava so I'm paying 1.4
megabytes for a mutable collection this
might be a very extreme example but
there's something that is more realistic
there as well which is Android plot
that's the second thing is C and that's
180k so by plotting library takes 180k
of apk size now there will be something
in there that I don't need because my
actual application that's the EU part on
there is only 35 K that's the code I've
wrote you might think 35 K for a hundred
lines of code that's a bit much what it
is because there's also auto-generated
code
most of which I actually don't need so
this brings us to the question how do I
get from this where you can clearly see
that guava an Android plot take the
majority of my apk size am and
replication is really small to something
that's more tailored that's more like
the thing that they did for Apollo of
course we won't get to something as
crafted as that without doing all the
investment but there must be some kind
of middle ground and that really is
where a tool like ProGuard
and r8 comes in because one of the
things that does it takes your
application and it removes all the
unused components so the goal is to take
a component alized built that you've
made into something as tailored as
possible and to remove all that code now
when I ask you you all said you know
you'll reuse this so you will know it's
really easy to enable because all you
have to do is you have to head back to
your built or Gradle file and then flip
this one flag right if Android studio
generated this for you then that will we
say minify enabled false you just flip
that to true and tada you have a small
app I see some people are shaking their
heads already here because of course
that's not really the truth so I did
this for my application I flipped the
flag and there was more than 200 build
time errors hooray so I looked at these
errors and I thought okay what are they
trying to tell me there's classes
missing classes I haven't even heard of
what do I do
how do I fix this well the first
solution you search on the Internet so I
did and I found this great piece of
advice which says just put don't want
star in to your pro guard configuration
and everything will be fine now
technically this is correct you put this
in there and it will compile but there's
a problem what this tells our aid is no
matter what happens don't tell me about
it and that means it will mask these
benign errors but it will also really
mask all the errors you actually care
about where something went wrong
so how can we improve on this and to do
that we have to actually deep dive a bit
into how our a it works now I will talk
about our ate here because that's the -
I helped build but most of this also
applies to prog art because it solves
the same problem so what does our I do
it has two things firstly it does
magnification a magnification is the
process where you take very long class
names and replace them by very short
class names instead some also call this
obfuscation but it really doesn't
obfuscate your code it just makes it a
little less hard to read but it's
nowhere safe for reverse engineering so
let's call this minification right
that's one thing Prager does but I don't
want to focus too much on that
the other thing it does is shrinking now
shrinking is a great name for this from
like a developer perspective because it
takes your app and it shrinks it into a
smaller app if you actually want to
understand what what happens under the
hood it works actually the other way
around because what we're doing is we're
doing tree growing which takes the entry
point of the application and grows that
until we've seen everything that will be
executed at run time let's look a little
here so I've tried this graphics and as
essence a box is a class that's all you
have to care about for now there's also
code in these boxes but don't read it
just yet another thing on these graphs
is that everything on your right is
library classes that's part of the
younger it system and everything on the
left is your application code and the
first thing to realize here is that
library classes are always live and
that's a very practical reason for us
because we can't shrink them away anyway
they're on the phone they're part of the
system but there's also a technical
reason because for a static analysis
tool we don't know what these library
classes actually do and that is because
the runtime might call into them at any
point there's very many different
libraries like different Android
versions and they also might change in
the future
so from an analysis standpoint we just
have to assume that
library classes are always life so let's
assume we will start our app by calling
the run method in the air class so the
first thing we will have to do to
actually do this is we have to
instantiate this F class which means we
create an instance of the class app and
we also call the constructor and that
leads to both of them being live that
means we cannot strip away the app class
and we cannot strip away the constructor
so far so good next we have to actually
look at the code of the constructor to
see what it will do at run time and if
you look at the code you will see it
actually creates a new instance of class
a so again this makes class a become a
life we can no longer remove it note
that class a doesn't actually have a
constructor so there's no code to look
at it only has a default constructor
that does nothing interesting here the
other thing that the constructor of the
app class does it writes the created
instance to this field other field
it's interesting to note here that
doesn't actually make other field life
because writing to a field is not
observable you have to actually read the
field to know that the field exists so
now we've created the instance of this
app class we've executed the constructor
we want to call the run method and again
calling this run method will mark this
method as life and with luck with every
other life method we now have to look at
it and see what the code actually does
at runtime so if you look at run you
will see it first reads the field other
fields to retrieve the instance and this
is the moment where this field actually
becomes live an X equal call a method on
the retrieved instance and that is where
a method in class a becomes life and now
we would look at the code of a method
see what that does and mark all those
effects so this is how the basic
analysis flow works whenever you think
about keep rules you have to keep in
mind this is what your analysis engine
will do now how does this relate to
Android how do we actually know the
entry point of an Android application
well that comes from your manifest file
so this is a very simplified manifest
file but one thing it does it tells you
that the activity has the class the
graph as its implementation now neither
r8 nor Prague are to understand manifest
files and they shouldn't because there's
a little tool that actually helps us
understand them and that's called a apt
apt during a build will precess
pre-process all your resources and it
creates corresponding keep rules for you
so let's look at this keep roll and this
is the first people so I will talk a bit
about it in detail so what it basically
does is says keep that's the simplest
form it says okay everything I mentioned
now you have to keep don't touch it
don't shrink it don't rename it and we
want to keep a class and then we have a
fully qualified class name which is my
main class that came from this manifest
there's something more here adjust the
class name would only keep the class it
wouldn't actually tell the system that
this class is also instantiated which is
a big difference to tell it about that
we also have to keep the Constructors
and that was this init line does so this
in it with the elided parameters tells
our eight we also need the constructors
and we will instantiate this at run time
so now our eight knows discusses life
and as I said before it will look at the
code let's go there
this is my the graph class and I've
removed all the function bodies and
everything that's not important but what
you will see here is it actually doesn't
have a constructor so that means our
analysis ends right here we've seen the
class there is no constructor nothing to
do now every one of you who's ever
written an end or lab knows the actual
meet happens in the oncreate method
that's where the actual configuration
happens so how does r8 know the keep
rule never told it to actually look at
on create what the trickier is that the
graph extends this amp compared activity
class and if you keep on following this
you will see that eventually that
extends activity
now activity is a library class and as I
said before all library classes are
always life
hence this oncreate method is also life
but as these on create in the library
classes life all its overrides in life
subclasses also become life and that's
another thing of the analysis you have
to keep in mind if you want to
understand how it actually works so this
is what marks on create life let's take
a look this is my own create method and
it looks like a standard on create
method it first does some setup
dedicates to the superclass I want to
highlight only two things here the first
is this find view by ID this calls a
library method and what it does it at
runtime dynamically returns an object
somewhere from your view based on your
layout again our eight cannot really
understand this because this ID is again
defined in an XML file somewhere this is
my layout and you can see it says this
XY plot class is in my constraint layout
and it has this ID plus how do we figure
this out in our eight again aapt comes
to the rescue
and this keep rule might look quite
similar but what it tells our eight that
your layout uses this XY plot class and
it will instantiate it at runtime so
it's always the same principle another
thing I want to highlight here is that
during this at plot serious where we set
up the plots we used another our
identifier which is this our dot XML now
our dot XML is different these are three
XML files you can just put in your XML
directory in your resources there's no
requirements on their contents so a apt
cannot actually understand them so when
you use these arrow Docs and L somewhere
you are responsible for all the keep
rules that may require just keep this in
mind we'll come back to that later so
this is the basic analysis flow this is
how this basically works now you might
ask okay
200 error messages how does that relate
what went wrong there I mean this
analysis looks reasonable why does it
fail and the reasons is that the
analysis that we do is different from
what the VM does and one difference is
annotations now the Android VM doesn't
really care about annotations at all
they have no meaning at runtime unless
you use reflection so if an annotation
class is missing the end rot VM will
still just execute that code because it
doesn't even look at them in comparison
our ate has to understand annotation
classes because they might be part of a
keep role
so r8 has to find these classes and has
to understand the hierarchy and if r8
can't it will warn you about it so
that's a very common source about these
warnings is missing a notation classes
the other thing is code RA just can't
understand here's an example which is
class value so class valley is a concept
from Java 7 but that's not available on
the Android platform so this code will
actually fail at runtime when the
Android VM tries to execute it it will
tell you this class is missing why does
this still work because the creators of
guava used this nifty trick here to hide
the missing class what they do is they
load the class via reflection and if
that fails they fall back to some
alternative implementation now the
Android VM will understand this at
runtime it will just throw an exception
the exception gets caught and the
alternative is executed but RA it cannot
understand this code it's just too
complicated to analyze statically and to
fix these errors you just really have to
look at all these examples and find
where they came from and ultimately that
got distills to these 5 key roles or
warning rules that you have to add now
the first three they just disable
warnings about certain annotations from
the Cheka framework and our approach and
those are just static analysis tool
frames that are not used at runtime at
all
the bottom two are two classes that are
not readily available on the Android
platform and they are typically used via
some reflective wrappers to make this
work
so adding these five rules we get our
application to compile that wasn't bad
right so we looked at better dead we
added five rules and tada we have a
small application
unfortunately the runtime behavior of my
application has changed just ever so
slightly because now it crashes and
that's the other problem you typically
see again what happened here right I
explained to you how the analysis works
that looked all fine and reasonable the
typical problem is reflection because by
its mere nature reflection is about
using a dynamic runtime value to load a
method or a clause in static analysis
just can't understand this dynamic
values are the enemy of static analysis
so how do we fix this well we have to
somehow figure out how to tell our aid
about these cases of reflection and make
our aid understand them and that's
really what keep rules do so what did I
do
I went to the Internet and fortunately
the developers of Android plot put up
this rule on the internet which says
keep class okay we want to keep some
classes calm Android plots
star star and what this means is that
tells our aid to essentially not touch
Android plot at all again this will fix
the problem
it will run again but it will no longer
shrink so this cannot be the point in
using our rate so how can we improve on
this and there's really no clever way
doing this other than going on some
forensics investigation we really have
to find out where all this reflection is
happening and what we have to add to a
dig configuration to make our 8
understand it so where do you look where
we find evidence and the first place to
look is the adb log so i've pre-process
this a bit here so that it's easier to
read but in essence if you go in Android
studio and lose the lock viewer you can
filter by process ID and this is in
essence what you will see
so there will be this Locke statement
saying that styler will definition not
found for a as such this is not really
helpful because I don't understand what
this is trying to tell me but it is
really great because it gives me a place
to look in the source code so this is a
big piece of advice if you write these
kind of libraries and you do reflection
put in logging statements it's not so
important that people actually
understand the message it's much more
important that people will find where
this statement was generated because I
have this logging statement there I can
now actually look at the code and see
what it's doing so here's plot Java and
yes you can see down there it says
locked or D star level finished not
found so what is going wrong here as you
can see this does reflection there's
this title class that get filled and
style class is a class object and get
filled will get a field from that class
given this name stylin aim so this is an
example of reflection on a class house
Tyla banane define because that's
clearly words going wrong it's trying to
find a field called a that seems a
strange field name this is hostile able
name is defined it's defined by means of
get class don't get named so again we
have to understand what this does what
does get class do that's again a
reflective invocation they will return
what's called in Java the current class
now if you're in this plot file and in
the plot class the current class can be
the plot class itself but it can also be
any of its subclasses because at runtime
this method might run in different
contexts depending on how the virtual
dispatch worked and then we get the name
of this class and this seems to return a
why did they name the class a well they
didn't
the problem is minification right r8
went ahead saw this class and thought
well plot is a long name let's call it a
so to fix this we have to prevent our
aid from renaming this class or any of
its subclasses and this is the
corresponding keep rule
so again what does it say it says keep
class calm Android plot dot plot and
that means our age should keep the class
not rename it not optimize it but as I
said we also have to keep all the
subclasses so we have to say keep class
star extends calm Android plot dot plot
this will keep all subclasses of plot
and the plot class itself but is this
actually what we want if you think again
what get class does it at runtime
returns the class of the current object
now you can only be the current class if
you've actually been instantiated but if
a class never gets created there is no
way of getting it via get class
so our keep rules do not actually have
to keep extra classes all we want is we
want to prevent them from being renamed
and that's where modifiers come in so
here's a modifier for you
well this now does it still says keep
but it says allow shrinking so tells our
rate if you see this plot class you
allowed to remove it if nobody uses it
but if you keep it
don't rename it and don't optimize it
and this will fix our problem because
now the plot class at runtime will
actually still be called plot S will be
all the subclasses so that was not too
bad right you look a bit at the code you
come up with to keep rules and your
application will run or not so it's
still not working we have to do more
forensics work what do we do we go back
to the adb log and the message has
changed we now see a different exception
again it's not really clear what this is
trying to tell me but I have an
exception I can look for
so this says error while parsing key
line paint or stroke width okay why does
this happen
how do we find out we look at the code
and here's the corresponding method and
I've highlighted the reflective views in
there for you
so again you can see we take a class and
then we get all its methods and next we
compare the name of this method against
some given name we're looking for
so there's two things that can go wrong
here we are just getting a set of all
methods so we might have removed too
many methods and again we're getting the
name of these methods so we might have
renamed them so these are the two error
conditions we now have to check what are
we removing
and whatever you naming that we
shouldn't now I have to admit it's kind
of hard to figure out what this code
really does unless you're the library
developer so the person who brought this
code initially knows perfectly clearly
what this is doing and at that point it
would have been really easy to write
these keep rules so what does this do do
you remember these so when we do this at
plot serious we configure what these
syria's are supposed to look like and
Endre plot has this really great feature
where you can tell it to configure your
graph based on some XML file and this is
what this XML file looks like and as you
can see in there you will find this line
paint dots block width and what this
library will do it will take this XML
file it goes through all the attributes
in there and then it will call
corresponding getters and setters on an
object it's trying to configure so we'll
take a graph object and then it will
call the get stroke get line paint
getter and then set the stroke width
property this is a very standard pattern
of configuring something at run time and
it's a really great feature but if r8
sees this it cannot understand this
because our rate cannot make the
connection between these XML file and
the actual classes also as this is
freeform XML we don't have a apt to help
us instead we have to do this ourselves
and this is the corresponding key pool
what do we need to do we don't want to
keep any extra classes because again
we'll be trying to do here is we're
trying to take an object at runtime that
already exists and then we try to
configure it by calling getters and
setters so that's what we use keep class
members that doesn't keep any extra
classes but it tells our aid if you're
already keeping a class in the command
replot package also keep these members
and don't rename them and what members
do we want to keep first of all we want
to keep getter
and what to get us look like they return
some result that's the three stars they
start with get and they typically have
no arguments
so that first line in there will keep
your getters similarly we can keep
setters so they don't return anything
but they start with set and they take a
single argument of some type so this
rule will now keep the getters and
setters so that the run time the
configuration can just happen so one
more keep rule do you think it will work
now let's take a look and yes we made it
so we added a couple of keep rules and
now our application is actually running
again
but was it worth it because this was a
bit of an investment right we had to
look at the code where to figure out
what it actually does what's this
journey worth while let's go back to the
apk analyzer and here you can see the
results so if you look at comb Google
which is guava that went from 1.3
megabytes to just 8k I know that's very
extreme because I'm using essentially a
couple of few classes in this huge
collection but also for Android plot
which is made more realistic you can see
that it went from 180 K to about a
hundred K and that's more than one
entire Apollo less also if you look at
my app you can see that it went from 35
K to 2k and 2k is a lot closer to the
hundred lines of code I actually wrote
because we removed all the unneeded
auto-generated parts that the build
system has created for us again I've
created this graphic for you to make
this a bit more visual and as you can
see guava nearly disappeared and her
plot haft and my app also turned into
this little sliver there so it was a bit
of a journey but it really really paid
off so what's the takeaway lessons here
I hope I was able to convince you that
it actually makes sense to look into
size but if you build an app no matter
what your target audience is please
invest in to size please invest into
creating keep rules
please use ProGuard or aid to actually
shrink your app
but also I hope I've shown you some
ideas of how to make this easier and the
first thing to really take away here is
you should consider size early on
because while you're writing your code
that is really really easy to also write
your keep rules because you still
understand what that code is actually
doing write all the code examples we
looked at if you had just written them
it would be easy to understand why this
goes wrong
also you should add structure to your
code to each describing reflective use
you remember this getters and setters
example I had where I said okay all
classes and Android plot keep the
getters and setters these kind of things
are much simpler if you actually have
some kind of interface that allows you
to tighten these up so if you had an
interface say runtime configured you
could just say in a keep rule every
object that extends runtime configured
keep these getters and setters and then
it's independent of the actual
application then it can just be part of
the library and lastly and this sounds
obvious but it's really important you
should continuously test an optimized
built again the earlier you find
regressions in your build the easier is
to fix them because you will still
remember what you actually changed and
it will make it easy to come up with
keep rules if you are library developer
you should really really carefully
provide keep rules because there's this
multiplier if you make precise keep
rules all the users of the of your
library will benefit from it and a lot
of apps will become smaller don't make
this an afterthought invest in to keep
rules while you build your library while
you design your library publish them
somewhere where people can find them
because that's typically what we all do
we will search the internet for rules to
use so put them on your home page put
them in the readme file make it visible
and lastly consider using consumer
ProGuard files when you're shipping via
the IAR system because this makes it
completely transparent to your library
users when they enable ProGuard they
will automatically get your keep rules
lastly please give us feedback so we've
built our age we have tested it we
believe it's a drop-in replacement but
only you can actually find that out so
if you're using ProGuard today give a
write a try
tell us how it worked for you if you're
not yet using ProGuard try out our rate
and see how far you can get with
shrinking on how good our diagnostics
our file box we have a really responsive
team and we really care about your
feedback and lastly after this talk you
can also seem at the sandbox or find me
outside if you want to have a chat and
with that I want to thank you very much
for your attention
[Music]